[Music]
how powerful are they up through jahad
let's start with their introduction and
origins then their description and
biology their powers and how important
they are in the hellboy universe but
first check out these two channels mind
cue space which will showcase
prehistoric animals and nutbuck which
will do the same but with robotics ai
cars and all
so anyway let's get to the video at hand
their introduction also known as
serpents are the bees the seven who are
one and the seven gods of chaos they are
a group of powerful entities that exist
in space and are the main antagonists in
the universe of hellboy they are the
seven headed dragon of revelations in a
biblical sense and are destined to bring
about the end of the world they are
pitiless chaotic bent on destruction and
subjugation and are so horrific in
appearance that looking at one of them
will induce madness the seven of them
are amon adat namrat ira
nun beu and nergal all having the suffix
jahad after their names
their origins the orc drew jahad which
is a collection of seven monsters were
created by a great spirit called anam
anam himself was created by god to
oversee the newborn earth
anam created the ogdrew jahad from fire
and mud and other spirits gusted spells
and wards around the seven beasts to
bring it to life but were useless in it
even infusing fire didn't awaken it from
its death-like slumber until it was
night time and it came to life
immediately reproducing its own young
ones called the orb through hem sending
them to earth to become the planet's
first life-forms when this was
discovered the other great spirits the
watchers trapped it in a prison of
crystal for aeons and ages
and destroyed its creator annum
description in the comics they appeared
as giant beasts that walk the earth the
audrey jahad's physical appearance
resembles that of theropod dinosaurs
while some of them look like serpentine
dragons with some amphibious traits on
the other hand unlike the dragon like
beings from the comic book source the
object heart from the movie designed by
wayne barlow resembled more of the great
old ones and the other gods of the
cthulhu mythos of lovecraft appearing as
massive cephalopods with crustacean-like
limbs and giant tentacles that serve as
their main locomotory organs
their biology taking the chance of their
worshipers into consideration bread in
the depths of the ocean neither male nor
female they are they are as the howling
wind which knoweth no mercy which knows
no pity so we can clearly see that they
are creatures that are genderless and
were originally aquatic in nature but
they could very well survive in deep
state of hibernations in any environment
including outer space they are also left
thick in nature being able to link
themselves to one another
by their minds and name seven who are
one
takes this into a whole new level
they have an ability to spawn offsprings
which are smaller than them but still
nonetheless very powerful
their powers the abdu jahad are mostly
inspired by the dragons of revelation
the outer gods of hp lovecraft with
ancient egyptian and babylonian
influences which means they have powers
beyond human imagination as we have said
so they have telephatic abilities to
communicate with each other as well as
humans they can also possess human
bodies and make them seem immortal and
indestructible by conventional damage
aside from these paranormal powers their
huge size is testament enough to the
amount of destruction they can cause on
a global scale
one of them called nun jahan could even
survive a nuclear explosion and attacks
from the watcher spirits which means it
is a cosmic level threat
their agenda it is unknown as to what
really is the plan of the akhdru jahad
but one thing is clear there could never
be a coexistence between them and
humanity whether it's humanity's
extinction that causes it to be released
from its prison of crystal or its
breakout from that prison that
eventually kills all of us it's still up
to debate as immorals and vastly
powerful entities whose true nature
defies reality and our imaginations
their true motives might be beyond us
and they might just be as indifferent to
our lives as they are to ants or
termites
but their worshippers believe that they
would destroy the earth burning it into
cinder
and then the entire universe so take
your pick either they are just a force
of malevolent nature like the
lovecraftian other gods or they are
intentionally evil like the biblical
demons
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well but most
of all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam